Je fais deux choses. Je conçois des ordinateurs portables, et j'étudie le cerveau.
La conférence d'aujourd'hui parlera du cerveau, et
super, il y a un fan des cerveaux dans la salle !
(Rires)
Maintenant, si on peut afficher mon premier slide là-haut,
vous verrez le titre de ma conférence et mes deux affiliations.
Donc, mon sujet sera la raison pour laquelle on n'a pas de bonne théorie de cerveau,
pourquoi il est important qu'on en développe une, et ce qu'on peut faire pour ça.
Et j'essayerai de faire tout ça en 20 minutes. J'ai deux affiliations.
La plupart d'entre vous me connaissent par mon travail chez Palm et Handsprings,
mais je gère aussi un institut de recherche à but non lucratif,
appelé "Redwood Neuroscience Institute", à Menlo Park,
où on étudie la neuroscience théorique
et comment fonctionne le néocortex.
C'est de cela en particulier que je vais parler.
J'ai un slide qui concerne mon autre vie, ma vie informatique, c'est celui-là.
Voici quelques uns des produits sur lesquels j'ai travaillé ces 20 dernières années,
du tout premier ordinateur portable à certaines des premières tablettes informatiques,
et ainsi de suite jusqu'au Treo le plus récemment,
et on continue à travailler dessus.
J'ai fait cela car je crois vraiment que l'informatique mobile
est le futur de l'informatique personnelle, et j'essaie de rendre le monde
un peu meilleur en travaillant sur ces choses.
Mais tout cela était, je dois l'avouer, totalement un accident.
En fait, je ne voulais faire aucun de ces produits
et très tôt dans ma carrière j'ai décidé
que je n'irais pas dans l'industrie informatique.
Et avant que je ne vous raconte ça, il faut juste que je vous parle
de cette petite image de graffiti que j'ai récupéré sur Internet l'autre jour.
Je cherchais une image de graffiti, un petit langage de saisie de texte,
et j'ai trouvé le site dédié aux enseignants qui veulent en faire,
vous savez, le script qui écrit des choses en haut de leur tableau,
et ils y avaient ajouté des graffiti, ce dont je suis désolé.
(Rires)
Donc, ce qui c'est passé, c'est que dans ma jeunesse, après être sorti de l'école d'ingénieur
Cornell en 1979, j'ai décidé d'aller travailler pour Intel.
J'étais dans l'industrie informatique, et au bout de trois mois là-dedans,
je suis tombé amoureux d'autre chose, et je me suis dit: "Je me suis trompé de carrière",
et je suis tombé amoureux des cerveaux.
Ça n'est pas un vrai cerveau. C'est une image, un dessin.
Je ne me souviens pas exactement comment ça s'est passé,
mais j'ai un souvenir, assez net dans mon esprit.
En septembre 1979, le magazine Scientific American
avec un numéro spécial sur le cerveau. Et il était assez bon.
Ce fut l'un de leurs meilleurs numéros. Ils parlaient de neurones,
du leurs développement et de leurs maladies, de la vue,
et de tout ce qu'on pouvait désirer savoir sur le cerveau. C'était vraiment impressionnant.
On pouvait avoir l'impression qu'on connaissant vraiment beaucoup de choses sur le cerveau.
Mais le dernier article de ce numéro était écrit par Francis Crick, connu pour l'ADN.
C'est aujourd'hui, je pense, le 50ème anniversaire de la découverte de l'ADN.
Et il avait écrit un article qui disait, en gros,
tout ça c'est bien joli, mais vous savez quoi,
on n'y connaît que dalle sur le cerveau
et personne ne sait comment ce truc fonctionne,
alors, ne croyez pas ce que quiconque vous dira.
Dans un extrait de l'article, il dit : "Ce qui manque ostensiblement",
c'était un vrai gentleman anglais, donc, "ce qui manque ostensiblement,
c'est un vaste cadre d'idées au sein duquel interpréter ces différentes approches."
J'ai pensé que le terme de "cadre" était formidable.
Il n'a pas dit qu'on n'avait même pas de théorie. Il dit,
on ne sait même pas par où commencer à y penser,
on n'a même pas de cadre.
On est dans un stade pré-paradigmatique, en se référant à Thomas Kohn.
Je suis tombé amoureux de cela, et j'ai dit, regarde,
on a tout ces connaissances à propos du cerveau. C'est si difficile que ça ?
C'est quelque chose sur quoi on peut travailler aujourd'hui. J'ai senti que je pouvais faire une différence,
et j'ai donc essayé de sortir de l'industrie informatique, pour entrer dans le domaine du cerveau.
Premièrement, je suis entré au MIT, où se trouvait le A.l Lab (NdT : Laboratoire d'Intelligence Artificielle du M.I.T)
et je me suis dit, je veux construire des machines intelligentes moi aussi,
mais pour faire ça, je vais commencer par étudier le fonctionnement du cerveau.
Et ils ont dit, oh, vous n'avez pas besoin de faire ça.
On va juste programmer des ordinateurs, c'est tout ce qu'on doit faire.
Et j'ai dit, non, vous devriez vraiment étudier le cerveau. Ils ont dit, oh, vous savez,
vous avez tort. Et j'ai dit, non, vous avez tort, et je n'ai pas été pris.
(Rires)
Mais j'étais un peu déçu - assez jeune, mais j'y suis retourné
quelques années plus tard, cette fois en Californie, et je suis allé à Berkeley.
Et je me suis dit, je vais y aller par le côté biologique.
Donc j'ai été pris - dans un programme doctoral en Biophysique.
J'étudiais enfin le cerveau, et je me suis dit, bon, je veux étudier la théorie.
Et ils ont dit, oh non, vous ne pouvez pas étudier la théorie à propos du cerveau.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on fait. Vous n'aurez pas de subventions pour ça.
En tant qu'étudiant en troisième cycle, vous ne pouvez pas faire ça. Donc je me suis dit, oh mon dieu.
J'étais très déprimé. J'ai dit, je peux faire une différence dans ce domaine.
Donc ce que j'ai fait, c'est de retourner dans l'industrie informatique,
et je me suis dit, bon, il faut que je travaille là-dedans pendant un temps, il faut que je fasse quelque chose.
C'est là que j'ai créé tous ces produits informatiques.
(Rires)
Je me suis dit, je vais faire ça pendant quatre ans, me faire de l'argent,
comme j'avais une famille, et je deviendrais un peu plus mûr,
et peut-être que les neurosciences mûriraient aussi un peu.
Ça a mis plus longtemps que quatre ans. Ça a pris 16 ans.
Mais je le fais maintenant, et je vais vous en parler.
Donc, pourquoi devrions-nous avoir une bonne théorie du cerveau ?
À vrai dire, il y a beaucoup de raisons pour lesquelles les gens font des sciences.
L'une d'elle - la plus basique - est que les gens aiment connaître les choses.
Nous sommes curieux, et nous allons juste chercher des connaissances, vous voyez ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on étudie les fourmis ? Parce que c'est intéressant.
Peut-être qu'on y apprendra quelque chose d'utile, mais c'est intéressant et fascinant.
Mais parfois, une science a d'autres attributs,
qui la rendent vraiment, vraiment intéressante.
Parfois, une science nous dira quelque chose sur nous-mêmes,
elle nous dira qui nous sommes.
Pas souvent, mais la théorie de l'évolution a eu cet effet. Copernic aussi,
et nous avons une meilleure compréhension de qui nous sommes.
Et après tout, nous sommes notre cerveau. Mon cerveau parle à votre cerveau.
Nos corps suivent, mais c'est mon cerveau qui parle à votre cerveau.
Et si nous voulons comprendre qui nous sommes, comment nous ressentons et percevons,
il faut vraiment comprendre ce qu'est le cerveau.
Un autre élément est que parfois la science
nous mène à de vraiment gros avantages sociaux et technologiques,
ou commerciaux, ou autres, qui en sont issus. Et c'en est un, aussi,
car quand nous comprenondrons comment le cerveau fonctionne, nous serons capables
de construire des machines intelligentes, et à vrai dire je pense que c'est une bonne chose globalement,
cela va avoir des avantages immenses pour la société,
comme une technologie fondamentale.
Donc, pourquoi n'avons-nous pas de bonne théorie du cerveau ?
Et il y a des gens qui ont travaillé là-dessus depuis 100 ans.
Tout d'abord, regardons ce à quoi ressemble la science normale.
Voilà la science normale.
La science normale est un équilibre entre théories et expérimentations.
Le théoricien dit, voilà, je pense que c'est ce qui se passe,
et l'expérimentateur dit, non, vous avez tort.
Et ça fait des allers-retours, vous voyez ?
Ça marche pour la physique. Et pour la géologie. Mais si c'est ça la science normale,
à quoi ressemble la neuroscience ? Voilà à quoi la neuroscience ressemble.
On a cette montagne de données, l'anatomie, la physiologie, le comportement.
Vous n'imaginez pas combien de détails on connaît à propos du cerveau.
Il y a 28000 personnes qui sont allées à la conférence sur la neuroscience cette année,
et chacune d'entre elles faisaient des recherches sur le cerveau.
Beaucoup de données. Mais il n'y a pas de théorie. Il y a une petite boîte timide là-haut.
Et la théorie n'a joué aucun rôle majeur en neurosciences.
C'est vraiment dommage. Comment ça se fait ?
Si vous demandez à des neuroscientifiques pourquoi il en est ainsi,
déjà, ils confirmeront. Mais si vous leur demandez, ils vous diront,
eh bien, il y a diverses raisons pour lesquelles on n'a pas de bonne théorie du cerveau.
Certains diront qu'on n'a pas encore assez de données,
on doit rassembler plus d'informations, il y a toutes ces choses qu'on ignore.
Mais je vous ai dit qu'on croule sous les données.
On a tant d'informations qu'on ne sait pas par où commencer pour les organiser.
À quoi servirait d'en avoir plus ?
On sera peut-être chanceux et on découvrira quelque chose de magique, mais je n'y crois pas.
C'est en fait simplement un symptôme de l'absence de théorie.
On n'a pas besoin de plus de données, on a besoin d'une bonne théorie à leur sujet.
Parfois, les gens disent que le cerveau est si complexe
que ça prendra 50 ans de plus.
Je crois même que Chris a dit quelque chose comme ça hier.
Je ne suis pas sûr de ce que vous avez dit, Chris, mais c'était quelque chose dans le genre de :
"C'est l'une des choses les plus compliquées de l'univers." Ce n'est pas vrai.
Vous êtes plus compliqué que votre cerveau. Vous avez un cerveau.
Et c'est aussi que, bien que le cerveau semble très compliqué,
les choses semblent compliquées jusqu'à ce qu'on les comprennent.
Ça a toujours été le cas. Donc tout ce que nous pouvons dire,
c'est que mon néocortex, qui est la partie du cerveau qui m'intéresse, a 30 milliards de cellules.
Mais vous savez quoi ? Il est vraiment très simple.
En fait, on dirait que c'est la même chose qui se répète encore et encore et encore.
Il n'est pas aussi compliqué qu'en apparence. Ce n'est pas le problème.
Certains disent que le cerveau ne peut pas comprendre le cerveau.
C'est très zen comme idée. Wow ! Vous savez...
(Rires)
Ça sonne bien mais pourquoi dire ça ? Ça mène à quoi ?
C'est juste un tas de cellules. Vous comprenez votre foie.
Il est aussi composé de beaucoup de cellules, pas vrai ?
Donc je ne pense pas que ça soit très juste de dire ça.
Et finalement, d'autres personnes disent
qu'elles ne se sentent pas être un tas de cellules. Qu'elles sont conscientes.
Je fais cette expérience, je vis dans ce monde.
Je ne peux pas être simplement un tas de cellules.
Les gens avaient l'habitude de penser qu'il y avait une force vitale,
et on sait aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas du tout vrai.
Et il n'y a vraiment pas de preuve qui dise... Enfin, à part les gens
qui ne croient pas que les cellules puissent faire ce qu'elles font.
Et donc, même si des gens sont tombés dans la fosse du dualisme métaphysique,
même des gens très intelligents, hé bien on peut rejeter tout ça.
(Rires)
Non, je vais vous dire qu'il y a quelque chose d'autre,
et c'est vraiment fondamental. Voilà ce qu'il en est :
il y a une autre raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas de théorie du cerveau satisfaisante,
c'est parce qu'on a une supposition intuitive, très ferme,
mais incorrecte qui nous empêche de vois la réponse.
Il y a quelque chose qu'on croît évident, mais qui est faux.
Il y a une histoire de ce type en science, et avant que je ne vous dise laquelle,
je vais vous en dire un peu plus sur l'histoire à ce sujet en science.
Si vous regardez certaines des autres révolutions scientifiques,
dans le cas présent, je parle du système solaire, avec Corpernic,
l'évolution de Darwin, et les plaques tectoniques de Wegener.
Elles ont toutes beaucoup en commun avec la science du cerveau.
Tout d'abord, il y avait toutes ces données inexpliquées. Un tas de données.
Mais elles sont devenues gérables une fois qu'il y a eu une théorie.
Les meilleurs esprits séchaient, des gens vraiment, vraiment intelligents.
Nous ne sommes pas plus intelligents maintenant qu'à leur époque.
Il s'avère juste qu'il est vraiment très difficile de penser les choses,
mais une fois que vous y avez pensé, il est relativement aisé de les comprendre.
Mes filles ont compris ces trois théories
dans leur cadre général en maternelle.
Ce n'est pas si dure, vous savez, voilà la pomme, voilà l'orange,
la Terre tourne, et tout ça.
Enfin, une autre chose est que la réponse était là depuis le début,
mais on l'avait plus ou moins ignorée à cause de cette chose évidente.
C'est cette croyance intuitive et fermement ancrée qui était fausse.
Dans le cas du système solaire, l'idée que la Terre tournait
et que la surface de la Terre bougeait à disons 1500 km/h,
et que la Terre fonce à travers le système solaire à environ 1500000 km/h.
C'est du délire. Tout le monde sait que la Terre ne bouge pas.
Est-ce que vous sentez que vous bougez à 1500km/h ?
Bien sûr que non. Et quelqu'un qui disait,
en fait, elle tourne dans l'espace et est énorme,
ils l'enfermaient, c'est ce qu'ils faisaient à cette époque.
(Rires)
Donc c'était intuitif et évident. Et maintenant, qu'en est-il pour l'évolution ?
C'est la même chose pour l'évolution. On enseignait à nos enfants que la Bible dit
que Dieu a créé toutes ces espèces, que les chats sont des chats, les chiens sont des chiens,
les gens sont des gens, les plantes sont des plantes, donc ils ne changent pas.
Noé les a mis dans son Arche dans cet ordre, bla bla bla.
Et vous savez, le fait est que si vous croyez en l'évolution, nous avons tous un ancêtre commun,
et nous avons tous une parenté commune avec la plant dans le hall.
C'est ce que l'évolution nous enseigne. Et c'est vrai. C'est assez incroyable.
Et c'est la même chose avec les plaques tectoniques.
Toutes les montages et les continents flottent de-ci de-là
sur la surface de la Terre. Ça ne fait aucun sens.
Donc quelle est la supposition intuitive, mais incorrecte,
qui nous empêche de comprendre le cerveau ?
Je vais vous la dire, et il va sembler évident que c'est juste,
et c'est là le but, non ? Ensuite je vais devoir expliquer
pourquoi vous avez tort avec l'autre supposition.
La chose intuitive et évidente est que quelque part l'intelligence
est définie par le comportement,
que nous sommes intelligents par la façon dont nous faisons les choses
et la façon dont nous agissons intelligemment. Je vais vous dire que c'est une erreur.
Le fait est que l'intelligence est définie par la capacité de prédiction.
Je vais vous guider avec quelques slides,
vous donner un exemple de ce que ça signifie. Voilà le système.
Les ingénieurs aiment regarder les systèmes ainsi. Les scientifiques, eux, aiment regarder les systèmes comme ça.
Ils disent "Bon, on a une chose dans une boîte, et il y a ses données d'entrée et de sortie."
Les gens d'IA (intelligence artificielle) disent que cette chose dans la boîte est un ordinateur programmable
car c'est équivalent à un cerveau. On lui fournit des données
et on lui fait faire quelque chose, manifester des comportements.
Et Alan Turing a défini le test de Turing, qui dit en gros
qu'on saura si quelque chose est intelligent s'il se comporte comme un humain.
C'est une mesure comportementale de ce qu'est l'intelligence,
et c'est resté collé dans notre esprit pendant un long moment.
La réalité, cependant, je l'appelle la véritable intelligence.
La véritable intelligence est fondée sur quelque chose d'autre.
On expérimente le monde à travers une séquence de motifs, qu'on stocke
et dont on se rappelle. Et quand on s'en rappelle, on les confronte à la réalité,
on fait des prédictions en permanence.
C'est une mesure permanente. Il y a une mesure permanente à notre sujet, qui nous dit en gros,
est-ce que je comprends le monde ? Est-ce que je fais des prédictions ? Et ainsi de suite.
Vous êtes tous intelligents à cet instant présent, mais vous ne faites rien.
Peut-être que vous vous grattez, ou vous vous mettez votre doigt dans le nez,
je ne sais pas, mais vous ne faites rien à cet instant,
mais vous êtes intelligents, vous comprenez ce que je dis.
Parce que vous êtes intelligents et vous parlez anglais,
vous savez quel mot se trouve à la fin de cette... (Silence)
phrase.
Le mot vous est venu à l'esprit, et vous faites ce type de prédiction tout le temps.
Donc, ce que je dis,
c'est que la prédiction permanente est l'output du néocortex.
Et que d'une certaine façon, la prédiction mène à un comportement intelligent.
Voilà comment ça se passe. Commençons avec un cerveau non-intelligent.
Bon, je propose un cerveau non-intelligent, on a un vieux cerveau,
on va dire que ce n'est pas un mammifère, plutôt un reptile,
disons un alligator, on a un alligator.
Et l'alligator a des sens très sophistiqués.
Il a de bon yeux, de bonnes oreilles, un bon sens tactile, et ainsi de suite
une bouche, un nez. Il a un comportement complexe.
Il peut courir et se cacher. Il connaît la peur et les émotions. Il peut vous manger, vous savez.
Il peut attaquer. Il peut faire tout ces trucs.
Mais on ne considère pas que l'alligator est très intelligent, pas dans un sens humain.
Mais il a déjà un comportement complexe.
Que c'est-il passé dans l'évolution ?
La première chose qui est arrivée dans l'évolution des mammifères,
c'est que nous avons développé une chose appelée le néocortex.
Je vais représenter un néocortex ici,
par cette boîte qui vient se coller au-dessus du vieux cerveau.
Le néocortex implique une nouvelle couche. C'est une nouvelle couche au-dessus de votre cerveau.
Si vous ne le savez pas, c'est la chose ridée sur le dessus de la tête,
elle a des rides parce qu'elle a été fourrée là-dedans et n'a pas la bonne taille.
(Rires)
Non, vraiment, c'est ça. Il a à peu près la taille d'une serviette de table.
Et il ne tient pas là-dedans, donc il s'est ridé. Maintenant, regardez comment j'ai dessiné ça ici.
Le vieux cerveau est toujours là. Vous avez toujours le cerveau d'alligator.
Vous l'avez. C'est votre cerveau émotionnel.
C'est toutes ces choses, toutes ces réactions instinctives que vous avez.
Et par dessus, on a ce système de mémoire appelé néocortex.
Et ce système de mémoire est posé sur la partie sensorielle du cerveau.
Donc quand les données sensorielles arrivent du vieux cerveau,
ells montent aussi dans le néocortex. Et le néocortex, c'est simplement la mémorisation.
Il reste là à dire "Ah, je vais mémoriser toutes ces choses qui se produisent,
où je suis allé, les gens que j'ai vus, les choses que j'ai entendues, et tout ça."
Et dans le futur, quand il verra quelque chose de similaire à nouveau,
dans un environnement similaire, ou exactement le même,
il le rejouera. Il se mettra à le rejouer.
"Oh, je suis déjà venu ici. Et quand tu es venu ici,
ceci s'est produit ensuite". Cela vous permet de prédire le futur.
Il renvoie littéralement le signal à votre cerveau,
et vous laisse voir ce qui va se produire ensuite,
vous laisse entendre le mot dans ma phrase avant que je ne l'ai dit.
Et c'est ce renvoi de signal dans le vieux cerveau
qui vous permet de prendre des décisions bien plus intelligentes.
C'est le slide le plus important de mon propos, donc je vais m'attarder dessus un petit peu.
Et donc, vous dites tout le temps, "oh je peux prédire les choses".
Si vous êtes un rat qui parcourt un labyrinthe, et que vous apprenez à le connaître,
la prochaine fois que vous vous y trouverez, vous aurez le même comportement,
mais brusquement, vous êtes plus intelligents,
parce que vous vous dites, "oh, je reconnais ce labyrinthe, je sais de quel côté aller,
je suis déjà venu ici, je peux voir le future." Et c'est ce qui se produit.
Chez l'homme, mais c'est valable pour tous les mammifères, au passage.
C'est vrai pour tous les mammifères, et chez l'homme, c'est devenu encore pire.
L'homme a en fait développé la partie frontale du néocortex,
appelée partie antérieure du néocortex. Et la nature a fait un petit truc ici.
Elle a copié la partie postérieure, la partie à l'arrière, qui est sensorielle,
et l'a mise dans la partie avant.
Et l'homme uniquement a le même mécanisme sur l'avant,
mais l'utilise pour le contrôle moteur.
Donc on peut maintenant effectuer des actions motrices planifiées très sophistiquées, des choses comme ça.
Je n'ai pas le temps de poursuivre dans les détails, mais si vous voulez comprendre comment fonctionne un cerveau,
vous devez comprendre comment la première partie du néocortex des mammifères fonctionne,
et comment elle stocke des motifs et fait des prédictions.
Laissez-moi donc vous donner quelques exemples de prédictions.
J'ai déjà évoqué la complétion d'une phrase. En musique,
si vous avez déjà entendu une chanson, si vous avez déjà entendu Jill chanter ces chansons auparavant,
quand elle les chante, la prochaine note apparaît déjà dans votre esprit,
vous l'anticipé au fur et à mesure. Si c'était un album de musique,
à la fin d'un album, la prochaine chanson apparaît dans votre tête.
Et ces choses arrivent tout le temps. Vous faites ces prédictions.
J'ai cette expérience de pensée, dite de la porte modifiée,
elle dit que vous avez une porte chez vous,
et pendant que vous êtes ici, je la change, j'ai un type
chez vous en ce moment même, qui change la porte,
il va prendre la poignée et la bouger de cinq centimètres.
Quand vous allez rentrer chez vous ce soir, vous allez avancer votre main
pour attraper la poignée, et vous allez remarquer
qu'elle se trouve au mauvais endroit, et vous vous direz, ola, quelque chose est arrivé.
Ça prendra peut-être une seconde pour vous en rendre compte, mais quelque chose a changé.
Mais je pourrais changer votre poignée de porte d'autres façons.
Je peux la rendre plus grosse ou plus petite, je peux la faire passer de laiton à argentée,
je peux changer son type. Je peux changer votre porte, la peindre,
y mettre une fenêtre. Je peux changer mille chose sur votre porte,
et dans les deux secondes qu'il faut pour ouvrir la porte,
vous allez remarquer que quelque chose a changé.
Maintenant, l'approche d'ingénieur, l'approche d'IA,
c'est de créer une base de données sur la porte. Elle a tous les attributs de la porte.
Et quand vous allez vers la porte, vous savez, vous les vérifier un à un.
Porte, porte, porte, couleur, enfin vous voyez de quoi je parle.
On ne fait pas ça. Votre cerveau ne fait pas ça.
Ce que fait votre cerveau, c'est de constamment établir des prédictions
sur ce qui va se produire dans votre environnement.
Quand je pose ma main sur cette table, je m'attends à la sentir s'arrêter.
Quand je marche, pour chaque pas, si j'en manquais un d'une fraction de centimètre,
je saurais que quelque chose a changé.
Vous faites constamment des prédictions sur votre environnement.
Je vais parler brièvement de la vue ici. Voici l'image d'une femme.
Quand vous regardez des gens, vos yeux sont attirés
deux ou trois fois par seconde.
Vous n'en avez pas conscience, mais vos yeux bougent tout le temps.
Et donc quand vous regardez le visage de quelqu'un,
vous passez typiquement d'un oeil à l'autre et du nez à la bouche.
Quand votre oeil se déplace d'un oeil à l'autre,
s'il y a quelque chose d'autre à cet endroit, comme un nez,
vous verriez un nez où un oeil était attendu,
et vous vous diriez : "Oh merde !", vous voyez...
(Rires)
"Il y a quelque chose qui cloche sur cette personne."
C'est parce que vous faites une prédiction.
Ce n'est pas comme si vous regardiez là et vous demandiez ce que vous voyez.
Un nez, c'est bon. Non, vous vous attendez à voir quelque chose de particulier.
(Rires)
Tout le temps. Et, enfin, regardons à la façon dont on teste l'intelligence.
On la teste par la prédiction : quel est le prochain mot ici ?
Ceci est à cela ce que ceci est à cela. Quel est le prochain chiffre dans cette phrase ?
Voici trois vues d'un objet.
Quelle est la quatrième ? Voilà comment on la teste. C'est la prédiction.
Dès lors, quelle est la recette pour une théorie du cerveau ?
Premièrement, nous devons avoir le bon cadre de travail.
C'est un système de mémoire,
pas un système de calcul ou de comportement. C'est un système de mémoire.
Comment est-ce que vous enregistrez et réutilisez ces séquences ou motifs ? Ce sont des motifs spatio-temporels.
Maintenant, dans ce système, vous prenez un tas de théoriciens .
Les biologistes ne sont généralement pas de bons théoriciens.
Ce n'est pas toujours vrai, mais en général, il n'y a pas une bonne histoire de la théorie en biologie.
J'ai trouvé que les meilleures personnes avec qui travailler sont les physiciens,
les ingénieurs et les mathématiciens, qui ont tendance à penser avec des algorithmes.
Ensuite, ils doivent apprendre l'anatomie et la physiologie.
Vous devez rendre ces théories très réalistes en termes anatomiques.
Quiconque se lève et vous expose sa théorie sur le fonctionnement du cerveau
et ne vous explique pas exactement comment le cerveau fonctionne
et comment les connexions cérébrales fonctionnent, ça ne fait pas une théorie.
C'est ce que nous faisons au Redwood Neuroscience Institute.
J'adorerai avoir plus de temps pour vous parler des fantastiques progrès que l'on fait là-dedans,
et j'espère revenir une autre fois sur cette estrade,
peut-être dans un avenir assez proche, et je vous en parlerai alors.
Je suis vraiment très excité. Ça ne va absolument pas prendre 50 ans.
À quoi ressemblera une théorie du cerveau ?
D'abord, ça sera une théorie sur la mémoire.
Pas comme de la mémoire informatique. Ça ne ressemble en rien à la mémoire informatique.
C'est vraiment très différent. Et c'est une mémoire
de motifs de grandes dimensions, comme les choses qui viennent de vos yeux.
C'est aussi une mémoire de séquences.
Vous ne pouvez pas apprendre ni vous rappeler quelque chose en dehors d'une séquence.
Une chanson doit être entendue en séquence dans le temps,
et vous devez la rejouer en séquence de la même façon.
On se souvient de ces séquences de façon auto-associées, donc si je vois quelque chose,
j'entends quelque chose, ça me le rappelle, et ça le rejoue automatiquement.
C'est un playback automatique. Et la prédiction des futures données d'entrée, ce sont les données de sortie souhaitées.
Et comme je l'ai dit, la théorie doit être exacte d'un point de vue biologique,
elle doit être testable, et on doit pouvoir la construire.
Si on ne la construit pas, on ne la comprend pas. Voici un dernier slide.
Quel va être le résultat de tout cela ? Est-ce qu'on va vraiment construire des machines intelligentes ?
Absolument. Et ça va être différent de ce que pensent les gens.
Ça va arriver, ça ne fait aucun doute dans mon esprit.
D'abord, on va le construire, créer le truc à partir de silicone.
On utilisera les mêmes techniques
que pour construire la mémoire informatique en silicone.
Mais ce sont des types très différents de mémoires.
Et on va attacher ces mémoires à des capteurs,
et ceux-ci auront une expérience des données du monde réel, en temps réel,
et ces choses apprendront des choses sur leur environnement.
Il est très peu probable que les premières choses que vous verrez soient des robots.
Non pas que les robots sont inutiles, et les gens savent construire des robots.
Mais la partie robotique est la plus dure. C'est le vieux cerveau. C'est vraiment difficile.
Le nouveau cerveau est en fait plutôt facile en comparaison avec le vieux cerveau.
Donc les premières choses qu'on fera seront celles qui ne requièrent pas beaucoup de robotique.
Donc vous ne verrez pas de C-3PO.
Vous verrez des choses comme, disons, des voitures intelligentes
qui comprennent vraiment ce qu'est le trafic, et ce qu'est conduire,
et qui ont appris que certains types de voitures qui ont le clignotant allumé pendant trente secondes
ne vont probablement pas tourner, des choses comme ça.
(Rires)
On peut aussi faire des systèmes de sécurité intelligents.
Là où nous avons besoin de notre cerveau, en gros, mais pas de beaucoup de mécanismes.
Ce sont les choses qui arriveront en premier.
Mais après cela, la limite, c'est le monde.
Je ne sais pas où cela va mener.
Je connais beaucoup de ceux qui ont inventé le microprocesseur
et si vous leur parlez, ils savaient que ce qu'ils faisaient était vraiment important,
mais ils ne savaient pas vraiment ce qui allait se passer.
Ils ne pouvaient pas anticiper les téléphones portables, Internet, et tous ces trucs.
Ils savaient que, eh, ils allaient construire des calculatrices
et des feux de signalisation. Mais ça allait être énorme.
De la même façon, la science du cerveau et ces mémoires
vont être une technologie fondamentale, et ça va mener
à des changements incroyables dans les 100 prochaines années.
Et je suis très excité quant à la façon dont on on les utilisera en science.
Je pense que j'arrive à la limite de mon temps, donc je vais terminer mon discours
maintenant.